الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون وجها لوجه
مع ازمه سياسيه بالغه التعقيد بعد تمرير
حكومته قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد من دون
تصويت الجمعيه الوطنيه
ماكرون تجاوز الغضب الاجتماعي العارم الذي
يعم المدن الفرنسيه وقرر استنادا على
الماده
49.3 من الدستور تمرير القانون الذي ينص
بنده الرئيسي على رفع سن التقاعد من 62
عاما الى 64
ورغم ان الرئيس الفرنسي يقول ان القانون
جاء استجابه للتدهور المالي الذي تشهده
صناديق التقاعد ولشيخوخه السكان فان
الشارع النقابي ومعارضيه يرون في الخطوه
نكسه له وانه
رهن رصيده السياسي بتمريره هذا القانون
تواصلت المظاهرات الرافضه للقانون في
مختلف المدن الفرنسيه وبينها باريس وفرقت
الشرطه التجمع في ساحه الكونكورد القريبه
من الجمعيه الوطنيه وقصر
وكانت قد شهدت الليله الماضيه اشتباكات
ومصادمات بين المحتجين وقوات الامن وجرعه
اعتقال عشرات الاشخاص حسب اعلان وزاره
الداخليه
واتخذت الشرطه اجراءات امنيه مكثفه مع
تجدد الاحتياجات واتساع رقعتها ودعوه
النقابات الى تجمعات محليه يومي السبت
والاحد وتكثيف التظاهر ليصل الذروه يوم
الخميس
في هذه الاثناء تسعى عدد من احزاب
المعارضه للتصويت في الجمعيه الوطنيه
لصالح اقتراحات بسحب الثقه من حكومه
اليزابيث بورن وتظاهر منتسب الحزب اليمين
المتطرف الوطنيون في باريس مطالبين
الجمعيه الوطنيه بالتصويت لصالح حجب الثقه
عندما يتم ذلك يوم الاثنين كما هو مرجح
حركه الاضرابات الشامله والاحتجاجات
الواسعه على قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
تنتظم فرنسا منذ السابع من هذا الشهر
وشارك فيها مئات الالاف ومنذ التاسع عشر
من يناير الماضي تظاهر الفرنسيون في ثمان
مناسبات رفضا للقانون
وعدت مجمل الاضرابات الى تعطل حركه النقل
واغلاق بعض المدارس وتكدس النفايات وتوقف
شاحنات الوقود بالاضافه لتاثر حركه النقل
بين فرنسا وعد د من الدول حيث الغيت عشرات
الرحلات البحريه والجويه ورحلات القطارات